hey guys here in Stockholm with my homie
from Arctic startup yon going to the
airport and heading back to NYC but in
this video I was actually in Hong Kong
doing QA some really interesting
insights some different stuff was pulled
out of me and so I hope you enjoy it and
I just want to thank all of you for
following me on on all the platforms and
if you haven't subscribed yet to the
YouTube and are just stumbling here or
continue watching it but aren't
subscribed to love that and super well
[Music]
please welcome the social juggernaut
himself mr. Gary Vaynerchuk and no
introduction for me thank you thank you
oh my god that's a big crowd Gary Vee
thank you very much for coming really
appreciate it
thanks for having me this is this is
incredible because as Brandon mentioned
I've been working on this for past six
months actually met your team in New
York City and we jumped a little bit so
it was amazing
but I don't want to spend too much time
on this I really want to give people a
chance to ask you some questions later
on but I want to set some context for
that because I don't know probably there
are some people that don't know you so
much so you know the first thing that I
want to talk about I watched the
interview with that he did with Tom from
impact theory and he did incredible job
and one thing that I really enjoyed was
the 51 449 Karma and practicality and
all of these things could you just talk
about that like like being a nice person
bringing value first what it means for
you and then we can deep we can go
deeper you know how other people should
manage it when they're just getting
started because I think that's that's
like super 11 for these guys because
we're just getting started we are not so
big as you are
but you know we should provide even more
value probably but also we need to focus
on the business right business side and
building it so
could you just talk about it little bit
sure first of all thank you guys all so
much for coming it's uh it's awesome
yeah I mean I think I think karma is
practical you know I'm I'm confused by
people's inability to understand how
human beings work and I think that a lot
of the reason that startups are gonna
fail at a record rate which is exactly
what's gonna happen over the next decade
is that so many people in this room are
gonna build their business in the eyes
of a VC not in the eyes of the market
all of their behavior will be predicated
on raising capital not on bringing value
you know at its core the reason I'm
answering this question that way is you
have to reverse engineer what you want
the greater your ambition for legacy and
something meaningful the greater you are
as a person because it's really the only
practical way to actually pull it off
you have to provide more value than you
ask for in return and so for me all I
want to do is from a you know when I
think about being an entrepreneur like
being an athlete I think about my life
when I don't have my Jersey on and I
think about what my life when I have my
jersey on and when I'm an entrepreneur
when I put on my jersey in the morning
you know there's two main goals in my
mind one to build the greatest legacy of
being an entrepreneur what I would
consider getting into the Hall of Fame
and and - that's my macro and my micro
is to be successful that day right
it's a day-in day-out thing so yeah I
mean my thesis is that I need to bring
more value in my content I need to bring
more value to my employees I need to
bring more value to my clients I prefer
the leverage of being more valuable to
you than you are to me it's actually
quite practical if I'm more valuable to
you than you are to me that ultimately
should work itself out for me
long term and I only play long-term like
really really long term like the end you
know and I and I don't think most people
do i I am so grateful that I'm wired and
parented in a way where when I was
making $50,000 a year that wasn't like I
just I'm gonna say something that
confuses me
I just think $50,000 a year is enough
money to live your life I don't know
like it's not enough if you want to have
a [ __ ] yacht in the [ __ ] water out
there but I I have not been driven by
capital and money pretty much ever you
know look at my actions versus my words
I built my family's business to a much
bigger business than it was I entered my
dad's business it was doing three point
something million dollars in sales I
left it as a business that was doing 60
million dollars in sales I owned zero
percent of Wine Library zero I then
started on the back of what I was doing
as a marketer a new company called
vaynermedia my brother AJ was graduating
from college he was no experience no
equity in the marketplace we started
vaynermedia and that company was 50/50
like I just am NOT driven by economics
and and that's fine because other and by
the way if you are great it's just that
I give more than I receive because it's
the game I'm actually playing and you
have to decide your game if your game is
predicated on you want to own a yacht
and a nice home and a gold watch then
that's fine then you should care about
short-term economics but short-term
economic strategies leave you vulnerable
you know what I love about you
did you actually care about people and
there are two stories so first I don't
know if you remember but first time we
met was actually in Lisbon so I was
waiting for you at the speaker
prep and I just wanted to have the book
sign and you arrived lay the bodyguards
were like you know pushing you cannot go
in and I told you like hey Gary I'm a
big fan I just won this book sign and
you said like oh I'm sorry I'm speaking
like five minutes but he went in you
just put your luggage there and then he
came out and sign my book and the same
thing happened I have a friend
Irish over there so I was sitting with
him yesterday and he took a selfie with
you at rice and like then he tweeted it
and you liked his tweet and he was like
going crazy about it you know like it
was like oh you know so so like I I love
this about you that he actually spent
the time now we're in a Tesla we were
driving here and you're like just
tweeting and like chickens to gram and
you're just doing it like all the time
the work ethic you know like you're just
online all the time if you were
privileged enough for people to actually
care that you like a tweet then you need
to take that responsibility and do
something with it like I will never take
four great I have been somebody who
loved entrepreneurship and and I didn't
call it entrepreneurship I'm old I'm 41
I called it being a businessman right
this was and everything and anything I
ever wanted to do
if you thought at any time in my teenage
years that I thought that being a
successful entrepreneur would lead to
people treating you like a successful
athlete or rockstar there was no part of
the vision that that was going to be any
part of it so the added value of
admiration is such a cherry on top it's
why I pushed people to do the thing they
love the most you don't know how the
world is gonna play out all my friends
who are such unbelievable video game
players in the 90s whose parents made
them stop playing video games to be a
lawyer none of us knew that eSports was
coming they could have been the Tony
Hawk right like you know like you don't
know where the world's going too many
people make decisions on how the world
is today and they're making decisions
about 14 years from now as if the world
will stay still so I can't wrap my head
around taking for granted
people thinking I'm cool and I will work
hard too
show my gratitude for the rest of my
life yeah but also it's amazing business
strategy because we were just talking in
a car about you know Paul
Jake Paul and Logan and they're just
building an empire just by doing YouTube
videos and engaging their fans and
basically just like showing them the
laughs so it's amazing business strategy
at the same time yeah but it's only a
nuance you can't show people love unless
you did something that made them like
you in the first place yeah
so what Jake and Logan Paul are are
incredible programmers and producers and
content producers for a new environment
no different than Steven Spielberg and
George Lucas were for the theater
environment of the late 70s like I think
we underestimate what it takes to be a
Kol in today's environment we think it's
easy for some reason because it feels so
remarkable that if you're cute or funny
or what like it just feels weird right
like oh my god like you know you're just
charismatic or have a nice smile or a
great figure and now all of a sudden
you're making you know a lot of money
the reality is being pretty always made
money it was called modeling you know
like being funny always made money you
just did it on stage that's what Richard
Pryor Eddie Murphy did and now you know
King bache might just do it on vine or
Instagram like nothing's new the mediums
are new do not have the audacity to
underestimate what it takes to have
enough success that a lot of people pay
attention to you do not underestimate
that you're thrilled to but the market
is smarter than you
awesome and now we're in Hong Kong right
this is your first time yeah it's your
first time Hong Kong
how do you like it I you know it's funny
d-roc and I landed yeah and we were we
didn't even leave baggage claim it's a
504 in the morning we're in baggage
claim and I looked at him and I go I
think I'm gonna [ __ ] love this place
it's been it's been an unbelievable trip
I texted my wife and said we're moving
to Hong Kong
[Laughter]
I'm not moving to Hong Kong I'm not
moving come on time but I it's uh look I
think a lot of I see a lot of familiar
faces there are people here do know me
yeah I need action Hong Kong has action
so it's interesting
well I guess China has action too and so
because you know on your dailyvees and
in your content you've been pushing
China quite a bit you know we have some
ambitions you know and the one of the
latest daily feasts are not latest
because you'd do it every day but you
know you were in con and you said you're
gonna dominate China in three years so
tell me like why China why do you care
about China right now and what's the
strategy that you get executing against
right now I don't know if you heard but
there's a lot of people there yeah I
mean you know one thing you know again
something that I think some of you've
heard I don't like talking about things
that I don't know and I don't have the
audacity to think that my brand or my
businesses can be successful in China
until I'm very thoughtful and committed
to giving that a chance and so you know
I'm starting to feel good about the
infrastructure of the Vayner machine in
a US standpoint in a European standpoint
and in to be very frank intuitively
intuitively I just feel like it's time
for Asia which is why I said yes to rise
which is why I said yes to the event I'm
doing in Singapore in October I've never
not a look not only have I never been to
Hong Kong I've never been to Asia
prior to this trip I mean you know I've
been I've been to India I've been to
Australia depending how you wanted to
find things but like I've not been to
this part of the world and ironically
the the purity of entrepreneurship and I
would maybe purities not the right the
rawness of the entrepreneurship in Asia
is far more aligned with my rawness of
entrepreneurship than the US or Europe
so I think it's gonna be very native to
me I'm excited about it you know I think
I have a humungous advantage and being
born in Soviet Russia
so I come with a lot of humility of the
amount of work and listening
I'm gonna have to do over the next two
to three years I you know I like
challenging myself yeah you know I feel
like I'm one of the only people on earth
that can literally amassed billions of
dollars and still be deemed a failure if
I don't buy the Jets you know I and so
when I sit like I'm gonna dominate China
three years that's to motivate me that's
me playing my own game for myself I
think I won't be doing anything close to
dominating China over the next two years
even though I'm gonna put in a lot of
work and then I think I'm gonna
understand and I'm gonna turn it on and
I do think in a three-year macro
five-year macro I'll have some success
because I think it's intuitive and
native and very aligned with my spirit
and I also think the youth the
entrepreneurial youth of China both on
patience and on their relationship with
their parents are gonna get a lot of
value out of my content awesome and
actually I just want to follow up on
this because you know you said you don't
like to talk about things that you don't
understand but like this morning we are
having breakfast and you actually or
actually lunch after lunch and you
actually know a lot of things about
China in terms of like where the Kol
industry is and this how do you do this
like do you have people in your team
that are doing it for you and then you
just analyze or do you actually read
something or how do you absorb this
information you know because you're so
busy running around the world and you
know speaking doing business so how do
you how do you manage this so d-roc
right before right when I got off a
stage right now back at the conference
said to me it's been really cool for him
to watch me navigate here over the last
two days he asked me did you read
anything about the market and I said no
he said and I think he intuitively
understood that that was gonna be the
answer
listen you know the one thing I think so
I think if you know who I am
I took you know if I say to you the word
hustle that seems very natural you know
I care about that I talk about that if I
say the word to you smart that feels
foreign because I never speak about it I
rarely if ever talk about how smart I am
I mean that and the reason I don't talk
about it is cuz I don't think that that
brings you any value
you know I think making you realize that
work ethic is a variable that is far
more controllable than almost anything
else that is a direct indicator on your
success is a valuable conversation I
think me telling you that the answer to
your question is that I absorb
information so quickly and synthesize it
through a filter that is so intuitive
that I'm successful at marketing and
communications is cool for me for myself
and I'm happy about it but not something
I speak to I think you know I think I I
understand human beings period end of
story
and I understand and I respect cultural
differences in nuances but no matter
what communist Russia Communist China
capitalistic America capitalistic London
we all have our cultures but there are
so many things that are tried-and-true
human no matter where you are and I
create on those things and it doesn't
take you long to read I have never heard
the term Kol 36 hours ago
I call it influencers yet but if you
call it Kol but I'll call it Kol like I
like these are semantics influencer
marketing is influencer marketing I want
to remind everybody here that I started
a vine agency for months after vine came
out but every person you know in America
a globally outside of China influencers
I've touched or knew before they like
blew up like my contest picked Logan
Paul to be the next vine start like I've
been in this I was an influencer on
YouTube in 2006 I was an influencer on
Twitter in 2007 these things are tried
and true I'm very good at pattern
recognition I'm very good at human
psychology and I'm extremely good at
humility in the early stages when you
have to understand the nuances
amazing so guys because we want to
provide some value here some questions
who has a question for Gary is there any
question yeah here do you track your
sleep or anything
I don't track my sleep I I invested in a
company called wake mate which was an
early like tracker technology back in a
day like 2009 but their first hardware
like combusted into flames randomly and
so they went out of business but that
was the only time I was close to ever
tracked my sleep I sleep six hours a
night like you know I try I'll sleep
more [ __ ] I wish I could sleep all the
time to be very like I I I hate the idea
that people think that I'm against
sleeping or that sleeping is not cool
sleeping's [ __ ] important I am far
more passionate about what you're doing
when you're awake than I am when you
sleep I'm not worried if you sleep eight
hours a day I'm worried that you're
[ __ ] around the other sixteen so I
think the sleep conversation needs to be
talked about more and defined and I've
been very aggressive rate first question
I just I'm curious and by the way I'm
only curious about what you're doing
sixteen hours a day when your mouth is
ahead of your actions if you're telling
me you're gonna build a hundred million
dollar company and you have any leisure
I'm calling you out on [ __ ] it's
hard enough to build a million dollar
business you know one that's actually
profitable so I try to sleep six seven
but I get plenty of fours and fives they
happen but I prefer not I mean one of
the biggest reasons I would think I want
to spend more time in asia's these
[ __ ] 16-hour flights I can get a nice
like eight nine ten and still get work
done yeah this was literally the
happiest day of my year so far was the
16-hour flight here I hadn't been
sleeping much because of serendipity so
I slept in
cathy has no Wi-Fi so I wasn't
distracted and ATD doubt so I had six
hours of work got my inbox to zero for
the first time in five and a half months
I [ __ ] land [ __ ] rest of his [ __ ]
inbox zero I'm like [ __ ] yeah better
question here cool thank you so we know
a ton about a lot of your successes
I was curious to know can you walk us
through one of your biggest failures and
what you learned from that I think you
know look I've only run two businesses
in my life and they're both gonna end up
being pretty [ __ ] successful I think
my failures are the things that I didn't
do like I don't think anything I operate
is gonna fail because I don't have
failure behavior I'm patient and slow so
I'm not overextending myself
I'm not driven by short-term capital so
I'm not over an extending myself I have
skill and was making $4,000 a weekend
when I was 12 years old selling baseball
cards so I'm a naturally good business
sales man I know how to run my [ __ ] I
don't care about what anybody thinks
about me so I never do behavior that
postures ahead of what I can afford so I
don't have behavior for operational
failure I think my failures are in all
the opportunities that I have I'm
crippled by opportunity every single day
I get three to four emails that are
batshit crazy right do this do that
take 50% of my company this become the
face of this TV show open this office
I'll give you my business buy this biz
like I'm crippled by opportunity I'm
saying no so much so many of those
things should have been yeses so yeah I
mean like Travis right I like Travis is
the only person I reference in my first
book besides my family yet I pass on
Ebers angel round at four million dollar
valuation twice you know my normal
twenty five to fifty thousand dollar
check you're talking about two to eight
hundred million dollar return that's a
failure you know and so but I don't you
know like like it's crazy right like
that's like game-changing right like I
think you know I don't know your psyche
but like saying no twice in time when
you were saying yes to a ton of [ __ ] you
said no to one of your best friends
twice and it turned out to be one of the
biggest companies of all time
I mean I don't know maybe it's like I
might have pulled off one of the biggest
failures ever I just don't even think
about it that way it's just the cost of
entry it's part of the sport I don't
dwell on it I probably have so many more
failures I'm just incapable of
synthesizing them the level of
disrespect I have for my failures is
overwhelming
I believe way too many people who
respect the [ __ ] out of their failures
[ __ ] your failures everybody else is
judging your failures
is there any way how we can train this
like that you don't care about your
failures and you know that you let
somebody down
I think it's predicated on self esteem
and genuine love for what you're doing
and so I don't know if that's teachable
but I do think there's a framework if
you ask me why my answer was just that
it's that I love losing as much as I
love winning cuz I love the game and
they both are like uber you know I think
you've got a read on this like I love it
so I talked about it yeah I love it I
[ __ ] love it and and and so I think
that's one and then I think self-esteem
I'm confident in a macro that I'll make
it up my vulnerability is being very
bitter in my elder years when I don't
have as much time I'm so happy to be
doing this that when I know that I get
to do this for another forty five years
it's hard for me to be upset about
something that happened five minutes ago
or last year or seven years ago what I'm
worried about my kryptonite is being 83
87 and knowing there's just not 20 years
to go right and so like that will be
something that I worry about to be very
frank with you I'm optimistic that I'll
sell myself on some other you know
fruits grandchildren who knows what but
it is something that I think about which
is um just so optimistic and it's
predicated on just more time and time
will go away
you are because this morning we had a
little bit of a mix-up in the morning
and I and I was like kind of upset you
know because like you're a busy guy and
I thought like I'm wasting your time if
I'm done if I'm not gonna deliver
exactly the thing that we agreed on but
he told me like no you didn't waste it
you didn't waste my time and like you
know we talked about some different
stuff but like you know for me it was
like that experience that I cared so
much about you and like not letting you
down I think too many people so look I
think money and success expose people I
don't think it changes them so yeah like
you had some other people that were
supposed to join our meeting this
meeting they didn't show up I don't
think my time is so much more valuable
than yours I just don't
so I did what I believe in the most
which is I adjusted to the situation
hello if people didn't show up and we
did some other [ __ ] oh so like I just
think the people that would make you
feel bad about that and by the way
plenty of important big people make you
feel bad about that
and I just think their [ __ ] faces you
know I love you I just I just think I
think that are imposing their
insecurities on you when they make you
feel bad about that awesome you have a
question here
and then hey Gary name tag I'm not that
good hello man I thank you for coming to
Hong Kong sharing your time with us of
course to have you you've touched a
little bit on intelligence of course
that's not what you really want to focus
on evangelizing work ethic the hustle
but what about purpose because you've
found the trifecta of harnessing your
intelligence doing the grind but for
people that are still trying to find
that purpose so that it's really mission
oriented so that they can sustain
themselves yeah what can you tell us
about finding your purpose I think you
need to try to go insular and taste
things like purpose is a fancy word for
happiness I think if you break it down
you know purpose what's my purpose
what's my why my homey Simon right yeah
its semantics like like for me
you know I I can't stress enough you
have the again and I'm gonna keep
pounding this cuz I need you to
understand when I was five I thought it
was when I was seven when I was nine on
a summer day I'm a kid of the 80s in
America which means you went outside and
you played right
I thought it was more fun to convince
manipulate whatever semantics or do you
want to use my friends into standing
behind lemonade stands or ringing
people's doorbells and washing their
cars like it's my true love right like
like and I don't think most people want
to follow their true love because a my
true love was building a business that
makes money which is very practical you
know I think if somebody's true love is
music they haven't figured out how to
make it monetizable because they have
friction because their true love is
something but they also want money and
stuff and I think that people waver
I think people struggle to find purpose
because they over value things and
people's opinions over their own true
happiness it's as basic as it gets so I
think that people I think everybody here
if I told them everything is gonna be
okay
you can have everything you want now
what are you gonna do with your day I
think a lot of people know it could be
anything if if you were to then watch
movies all day like if we played this
game and you're like okay everything
well [ __ ] I don't do [ __ ] I just want to
watch movies cool I think you should
build a business around that right like
to me like great right so like I think
people are scared
I think people are scared I think
they're scared what people will think
and I think they're scared that they
can't survive living the life that they
want to live from a materialistic
standpoint what makes me so dangerous
because I don't need anything I don't
need anything I don't need anybody and
that's it and so I'm good and and I wish
that on everybody you know nice it is to
not rely on anybody for anything at all
ever not emotionally not financially not
just as it's the Zen zone but purpose is
to make yourself happy I'm a nice guy
cuz I like admiration and so I have to
give it that's my purple but but it's
all predicated making me happy I'm nice
because it makes me feel good what they
say about me yeah like like you have to
understand it's very basic and so yeah I
think people are scared I listen if I
could ever convince you that you don't
need [ __ ] you would be off to the races
if you could unmaterialistic yourself
you'd be [ __ ] [ __ ] you know over
there need a girl I've been working on
this startup myself and I despite
everyone being really nice I've always
noticed that there's sort of like you're
a bit too young to do this yes how do
you get past the stereotypes or
limitations I think you know the answer
Hilary I think it's in your own head
right like the bottom line is do you
agree with them great you're on your
[ __ ] way right like like like listen
I is your mom here like leadership like
you know like like you're ready you've
already won right like your question -
do you want to hear something
interesting like I don't think you even
believe in the question that you just
asked me and that is the ultimate
compliment because spending time with
you backstage yesterday like I think
that's a cute question but I actually
don't think you give a [ __ ] do you give
a [ __ ] of what people think
occasionally right I respect that
sorry I'm I'm I'm gonna tell you
something really or 12 right yeah so I'm
gonna tell you something super exciting
when I was 12 I occasionally cared what
people thought too that [ __ ] goes away
real quick that's the answer I'm so what
like what your teacher or your uncle
Rick [ __ ] thinks that you should
you're too early like it's just not
gonna matter at the end Hillary here's
what's gonna happen either you're right
or they're right that's what's gonna
happen at the end spending any time
debating who's cheering for what outcome
or what point of view is a complete
waste of your energy so we have maybe we
have time for like two more quick ones
so yes yeah because we have cool so we
have more okay please hi Guardian with
the magnet back right like people look
back you want to ask a question right
just raise your hand then hi Gary this
is Mac I have a question you know
exactly Silicon Valley Valley
Silicon Valley and then values and the
businesses people over there Hong Kong
Singapore a lot of places in China wants
to kind of copy this kind of values as
standards what they are and how we can
learn from this place over there so ah
that would make me Mak that would make
me really sad if Asia started
replicating Silicon Valley standards you
know well first of all if you look at
for example the Chinese social network
ecosystem and platforms they because of
the payment integration have much better
business models like you know Silicon
Valley bless you
Silicon Valley Silicon Valley VC let's
let's leave it freeze it's not Silicon
Valley when people say Silicon Valley
what we're referring to is venture
capital
the venture capital model is very
practical stress all your companies to
be non-practical so that one gets
through and makes your fun return on its
non practicality all that's happened in
the last seven years of putting venture
capital business mindset to the
forefront is we've taught a lot of
people to not be entrepreneurs we've
taught a lot of people of how to worship
fundraising not business building the
number one mistake Asia would make is to
follow the Silicon Valley blueprint
that's it man it's in a if you're
talking about innovation like innovation
will always matter but innovation
happens all over the world Silicon
Valley is just where kids go after good
[ __ ] happens like like Facebook was
invented in Boston Pinterest was
invested invented in Pennsylvania like
like you know it's this is such this is
the same [ __ ] that universities
trade on Silicon Valley trades on brand
Harvard trades on brand these these
things are not as valuable as we think
we're worshipping the wrong thing so how
can you prove on it what can you take
out of it look I think the
entrepreneurial spirit is very alive and
well in Asia I think it's a unlike other
parts of the world it is a religion here
just like it is in America so I think
that's the cost of entry its optimism
it's where failure isn't the death blow
in society it may hurt but it's not a
death blow really tough to fail in an
entrepreneurial venture in Western
Europe really tough so I think that um I
think spending any time you know even I
mean my best advice for Asia is to not
pay attention to America at all
another question somewhere you have
migrated hi Gary my name is shin my
question is with so many opportunities
coming your way how do you decide the
people you want to work with and
collaborate with in tuition and tuition
to be honest with you what a [ __ ] answer
right because it brings no value to
anybody here other than I just have to
tell you the truth it's [ __ ] like it's
what I go on you know it's because I'm
willing to fire fast people have their
ego tied up into hiring it's insane
hiring is such a subtle thing
partnerships hiring and investing such a
subtle thing people love to be romantic
about their judgement and character thus
it deems them non-actionable when it
most matters guys humility is the game
I've got plenty of bravado and
peacocking I understand why it might be
hard to see my humility but humility is
my strength I intuitively think that
person is awesome I get to hang out with
them for a week I realized they're an
idiot I need to move
most people disguise it so that people
didn't think they made they'll call
wrong in the first place cool is there
any other question I have a question
sorry thank you so much Gary for being
here um what is the one question that no
one is asking but that everyone should
be in your opinion god this has been
such a tough question when it's come up
I it really is this is one of the
toughest questions ah to really answer
your question properly the question they
should be asking is the thing that
they're most scared to say out loud the
question they should be asking is hey
Gary its shin here you know so my dad is
insecure and thus it's manifested it in
a way where he's making me do this I
love my dad but I don't want to do this
and it's causing real friction
to my household and my mom is of a
generation that she blindly listens to
my dad and this feels very toxic what
should I do
that's the question and every other
question that looks like it right the
question that should be asked is the one
that nobody wants to say out loud
cuz it exposes them over there in the
back
I don't Gary hey are you very well I'm
from China
gradually I'm with your Chinese
translation team here so my question is
about kind of about the retail business
retail yeah so for the past ten days
there has been a article in a WeChat
it's been reposted by two thousand and
eight hundred accounts and read one
hundred million times I hope I really a
small numbers by China standards it's
kind of big on Louisa by the way I
really wish that it was one of your
articles we'll see it's about it's about
the new supermarket the article ba has
recently open okay there's no human
being on it there's no human beings yeah
you just you just Wendy and then it grab
the grab the product and went out and
then the payment would be deducted from
your IRA paid account phenom yeah so I
can literally not wait for the robots to
kill all of us
okay okay sounds good so online Giants
they're going back to offline they the
similar case would be Amazon open the
first physical store beckons 2015 in
Seattle and a few weeks ago Amazon just
bought hopefully yeah so the Giants
they're on on lines they are they have
all the money and resources to do that
that's good yeah it's a good it's a good
my question is just you don't have this
all plays out right yeah you know
consolidation and then fragmentation
consolidation so experimentation it's
going to be the next generation debris
their business
of course my man what always happens in
the history of time of capitalism is
once in a generation entrepreneurs come
and gobble up the landscape and become
the legendary figures of their
generation and then they either get fat
and slow and young companies find angles
within it
or they die and then different people
come and run the company that suck but
like these are just cycles we had a new
frontier it was called the internet it's
changed everything it's still very young
Pioneers land grabbed the same way that
people bought up property thousands of
years ago hundreds of years ago right
and the under and the mods and the
bezos's they become these iconic people
then they either die or stop running the
companies and then youngsters see the
vulnerabilities in the new thing do you
understand that in 20 years they'll be
virtual reality and then every piece of
infrastructure in our physical and
Internet world will become vulnerable
and there'll be new people that land
grab and the new Maas and a bezos's
Karen MA is gonna start a virtual world
where she owns all of the retail world
because everything now becomes virtual
because that's how we communicate and it
augmented you know world and so cool
yeah great I'm glad my [ __ ] wallet
going to [ __ ] the store yeah totally
so what's the question
so as the trend is coming what is the
potential threat and the opportunity for
the individual online retailers the
littler ones the individual like you
encourage people to sell things on eBay
so there's my man how much do you think
Amazon and Alibaba and everybody else
what percentage of every transaction in
the world do you think they'll
ultimately own I have no [ __ ] idea no
problem let me let me give you an answer
not enough to allow trillions of people
to make tons of money
yeah sure makes sense the end Thanks
you're welcome I guess
we have really we have time for one more
and then we need to move on because you
have other meetings okay so one more
guys
hi Gary I'm mint from staff corn
guangzhou chapter and I have a question
it's like like a question you just
mentioned okay like I'm a young
entrepreneur
yes I'm now in a stage that I want to
catch every opportunity in front of me
okay
and like and I think everything is
important everything like a big benefit
to my life
so I want to we have a suggestion of how
I choose this thing cuz allow every time
every day as they've only four hours
right - so very big that's really a
problem I think the answer is to not
judge yourself not judge myself that's
right
so you're deploying 20 hours of taking
advantage of all these opportunities
right yeah the reason you asked me that
question is you're laying a bed right
before you go to sleep for your four
hours and you're questioning yourself if
you did the right things with those 20
hours instead of the other things you
could have done right mm-hmm so you're
judging yourself okay so the punchline
to that question and answer is this you
will never be able to do everything give
unlimited years you're such a fortunate
young woman you have unlimited you're
crippled by opportunity yeah so just do
as much [ __ ] as you can in your 20 hours
mm-hmm and then wake up the next morning
and do it again but never think about it
ever again okay sure thank you
so ten seconds ten seconds ten second
question if you have over there yours
yeah yes I don't know if this is gonna
be quick I'm Adrian Aryan so taking a
slightly different turn with all the
entrepreneurial stuff that you do what's
the biggest tip you have we're dealing
with your wife and what do you do not
what do you not compromise on with your
kids so two things with my wife and
with any relationship you have you first
have to make yourself happy because if
you're not happy you have vulnerability
to the entire ecosystem so this is
something that is super politically
incorrect this is not the answer that
most people like here or want but I'm
selfish which allows me to be selfless
how do I handle with my wife I over
communicate with her and keep checking
in and we talk about it all the time as
our lives evolve what is non-negotiable
what is what isn't I in the last three
four years I'm spending more time with
my family not less it doesn't feel that
way because of the way I'm doing content
and distribution but I am you know and
then it's compounded because one of the
lines in the sand is we don't show our
family to the world so you don't see
content about my two kids or my wife
ever the most searched term besides me
Gary Vaynerchuk is Gary Vaynerchuk wife
because you know followed very closely
by Gary Vaynerchuk net worth so so you
know so I just communicate and my hope
is that I create a framework that makes
her feel comfortable to communicate
things to that she wants to say that I
may not want to hear right
the non-negotiable things with my kids
is if I am in New York City and they
have a function I will not miss it so
there is no meeting there's no CEO no
famous person no business opportunity
that will trump a recital or a play if
I'm in New York but I miss things all
the time because I'm not in New York and
I don't judge myself right so I do the
best I can and I think the political
correctness of parenting and work-life
balance right now is a very hot topic
and I try not to talk about it too much
because we all have different
relationships and different situations
nobody knows what's going on in my
bedroom and I don't know what's going on
in yours
I think it's about communication with
the only people that matter you can
judge my work-life balance from afar I
just don't give a [ __ ] but I really care
what my wife
right communication awesome we don't
have enough time we could be cheering
for like 15 hours so before we go on
guys if you have the books those who
bought the books please line up over
there at the table and we are gonna do
some book signing but before you know we
sold some tickets for this event but
what are we gonna do with the money
we're actually going to give it to
pencils of promise that's awesome so I
just wanted to mention it because I was
in touch with them and they said that
they are gonna be very happy about that
yeah and can we take a picture dairy are
you around because I have something for
you because this is the first time in
Hong Kong and I want you to remember it
a lot so we have a t-shirt garyvee
hustling in Hong Kong 2017 and and zero
can you come here as well we have
something for you as well because you're
also hustler so we have a t-shirt for
tearing as well give me can we take a
pic hope you guys got value out of that
would love for you to help me clip some
Instagram clips so put timestamps in the
comments of the one-minute clip that I
should use that's a new insight or fire
that you enjoyed see ya
[Music]